[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 sport sur tv 78 l'émission à ne pas
manquer si vous êtes un passionné de
sport local c'est parti pour le sommaire
de ce magazine football énorme coup de
projecteur dans ce magazine sur la demi
finale de la coupe de france avec ce
match tant attendu par les yvelines nice
versailles à l'alliance riviera
interviews reportages en ce 7 8 sport
breakdance une démonstration du pôle
espoirs de l'équipe de france étaient
organisées aux mureaux occasion de
découvrir cette discipline qui sera
présente aux jeux olympiques de paris en
2024 enfin retour sur les résultats
sportifs du week-end dans les emails
notre chroniqueur bixente mérian senti
steban l'actualité sportive c'est
maintenant sur tb 78
on commence donc par du football c'est
le match à ne pas manquer est cette
semaine versailles leader de nationale 2
se déplace à nice troisième de ligue 1
pour tenter de décrocher son billet pour
la finale de la coupe de france
plusieurs centaines de supporters ont
prévu de faire le déplacement pour le
rendez-vous dans les yvelines la
rencontre est à suivre dans les bars la
mairie de versailles n'a pas reçu
l'autorisation de la part des diffuseurs
pour organiser une retransmission sur
écran géant place du marché à
rendez-vous que les joueurs versailles
ont préparé tout au long de la semaine
dans les yvelines entre versailles et le
centre national du football à
clairefontaine aux équipes les ont
suivis sur ca derniers jours avant leur
départ pour le sud de la france regardez
les images de patrick jacques de dixmude
céline charles et bixente mérian
santisteva
mercredi 23 février après une séance
d'entraînement direction but que pour
les joueurs et le staff versailles et
les demi finalistes de la coupe de
france sont invités par ce magasin dans
le cadre de l'opération petit poucet ils
se sont vus remettre des maillots et des
écharpes devant plusieurs dizaines de
supporters
les événements ont ensuite pu approcher
le fameux trophée de la coupe de france
c'est un plaisir de voir cette coupe
présente sachant que la troupe de france
marc présente tellement de choses pour
les français cette proximité avec les
gens des valeurs de solidarité donc
c'est pour ça que
c'est plaisant et qu'on conçoit
aujourd'hui ici ça fait plaisir à nos
joueurs et à tout le vin le lendemain
retour à l'entraînement pour une séance
classique avec quelques invités des
caméras et des journalistes venus de
france et de l'étranger sont présents
pour cette journée médias l'occasion
pour les joueurs de mesurer l'ampleur de
l'événement et avaya de la ferveur qui
se propage autour de nous et franchement
ça nous donne encore plus d'énergie
positive pour pouvoir gagner ce match
pour pouvoir aller au moins au bout de
la coupe quoi samedi dimanche à deux
jours de leur demi finale face à nice le
petit poucet binois s'est préparée sur
les terres de l'équipe de france grâce à
l'un de leurs sponsors au centre
technique national de clairefontaine par
contre pierre fontaine c'est le repère
de l'équipe de france et essayer quand
on est petit on voyait envoyer nos stars
ici et là le fait d'être là elle fait
devant château dans les chambres des
joueurs c'est la préparation elle est
parfaite on l'avait déjà fait avant le
match de toulouse ça nous a apporté ses
fruits ac 1 du mythique pour le football
français quand on regarde et à la claire
fontaine ou d'autres reportages ou même
que tu quand on sait que tous les
joueurs de l'équipe de france jeunes ou
adultes se regroupent ici et que nous on
a la chance de profiter de ces
installations c'est magnifique
l'occasion également de voir une
dernière fois leurs supporters ils sont
venus en nombre pour ce dernier
entraînement dé versailles et dans les
yvelines vu le parcours qu'ils ont fait
c'est sûr que c'est bien de pouvoir
venir les soutenir ont battu à une
équipe de ligue 2 qui tint scène vrai
régal c'est tout
ils ont ainsi pu se battre est arrivé
jusque là je pense que contre nice plus
les fêtes continuent leur beau parcours
on passe de deux j'ouvre peut-être le
coup on est mis comme ça en exergue
franchement c c'est bien pour le club
c'est bien pour la ville aussi qu'on
soit connue pour autre chose que pour
château quoi donc c'est bien c'est bien
pour les gens du club pour les bénévoles
pour les joueurs pour le stage s'est
bien pour
pour la coupe de france aussi c'est
important aussi que des fois que le
petit poucet qui passe cailloux sur quoi
je contemple un plaisir plein de bonheur
de pouvoir partager ça avec eux c'est
pour ça aussi que quand on joue au foot
c'est pour partager des émotions comme
ça c'est un plaisir un élan en temps
déjà que nous on est ultra motivé mais
les entendre se le dise à se lever le
matin venir y fait pas très chaud bon il
ya un petit peu de soleil mais c'est pas
très chaud mais venir nous encourager
comme ça pendant toute la séance ben
nous on sent que pour eux c'est très
important et franchement comme j'ai dit
ça nous donne de la force à nous donne
envie de nous surpasser déjà pour nous
et pour eux encore plus donc ouais
franchement prononcé super un bâton et
je vous renversez se sont ensuite
envolés pour nice dans la soirée de
dimanche pour préparer au mieux le
rendez vous une nouvelle semaine
historique pour le club et les yvelines
on continue à parler de cette demi
finale de coupe de france nous avons
rencontré jean luc arribart le directeur
général du club lors d'un entraînement
regardez la séquence jean luc arribart
est à mes côtés alors jean luc arribart
comment ça se passe dans cette dernière
ligne droite avant cette demi finale de
coupe de france ça se passe très bien où
ils les joueurs sont en train de
s'entraîner avec beaucoup de d'appétit
beaucoup de bonne humeur et beaucoup de
sérénité et du coup pour pour ce match
vous pensez que tous les éléments sont
en votre faveur où ça va être un peu
compliqué d'aller à d'aller à nice alors
honnêtement n'est pas les favoris comme
de ceux de cette demi finale
on sait que c'est un énorme adversaires
qui se présentent à nous qui va jouer
chez lui donc malheureusement on a un
peu tous contre nous mais on va essayer
encore une fois de faire le faire
l'exploit de de tout donner pour essayer
d'aller jusqu'en finale de monter cette
dernière marche est très haute en fait
pour jouer en région parisienne il faut
aller en finale si je comprends bien
balawi a plus de plus le choix c'est une
promesse que je tiendrais on jouera le
prochain match de coupe de france cette
saison à paris au stade de france et y
sera plein et du coup il ya un petit
regret forcément sur sept ce déplacement
à nice plutôt que de recevoir en région
parisienne où finalement
vous les joueurs sont là compris ce
n'était pas possible et ça sera comme ça
tout simplement il ya un seul regret
celui de pas avoir joué au parc des
princes qui n'étaient pas disponibles
malheureusement parce que c'était le
souhait de tout le vestiaire de jouer au
parc des princes à l'origine ces jouets
même contre le psg au parc des princes
bon là et je étant éliminé n'aurait aimé
jouer contre nice au parc des princes ça
n'a pas été possible on l'acceptent mais
c'est le seul regret qu'on a parce
qu'après les les les problématiques
d'organisation de sécurité les coûts
étaient beaucoup trop élevées par
rapport aux risques de d'affluence qui
aurait été moindre si on avait joué
sur les stades qu'on avait envisagé y
compris
par exemple à trois qui nous proposait
gentiment à lens aussi on avait imaginé
avoir l'appui du formidable public
lensois mais bon c'est pas notre public
c'est pas il n'y a pas de lien
particulier entre lancé et versailles
puis c'est loin de paris donc il n'y a
pas d'autres regrets que celui du parc
des princes est aujourd'hui jouer à nice
c'est quand même pas mal quoi c'est
l'alliance riviera c'est un magnifique
endroit pour y jouer une demi finale de
coupe de france donc je pense que de
toute façon sportivement il avait un
avant ils ont un avantage sur nous quel
que soit le terrain ils le gardent à
nice ils seront peut-être peut-être un
peu trop confiants c'est peut-être là
dessus qu'on va jouer et puis peut-être
que les les faits de matchs seront en
notre faveur en tout cas falloir qu'on
ait un coup de main pour essayer de
rivaliser essayer de de passer où vous
étiez à combien de % de chances à peu
près de passer sans aller à nice et
maintenant on a un indice à s'en aller à
nice je dirais qu'on a et 10%
en allant à nice
et du coup les supporters vont être peu
nombreux dans le stade entre 70 et 80
personnes qui est qui qui qui vont venir
comment va comment ça se passe du coup
un déplacement pour les supporters
on va
tout faire pour l'organiser dans les
meilleures conditions en voyant déjà
qu'ils se débrouillent de leur côté
évidemment non on va on est en train de
travailler avec l'association pour
pouvoir le leur permettre de venir dans
les meilleures conditions et les aider à
venir là bas et évidemment qu'on va être
submergé par les supporters niçois je
crois que ça marche en plus très très
bien la billetterie là bas on parle
d'une influence de 25 30 mille
spectateurs dont ce qui va être vraiment
très bien un environnement d'un stade
pareil pour une demi finale c'est ce
dont on rêvait je pense que les joueurs
vont être ravis de de faire ce match
dans ces conditions là et et nous on
aura quand même nos petits supporters
dans un coin qui vont faire du bruit et
qui est on aura on aura une présence
amie on va dire dans un petit coin du
stade ils viendront en avion normalement
et non pas en bus comme ça avait été le
cas à périgueux voilà ça fait un peu
loin quand même pour aller à nice
m'enfin ils sont c'est des fous furieux
quand même ils sont courageux ils sont
prêts ce levé à pas d'heure et puis à
faire huit ou neuf heures de bus donc on
sait que ce sont les les plus courageux
qui se déplace toujours qui nous suivent
partout là je pense qu'ils vont créer un
avion est ce que oui aller en bus et là
c'est un peu beaucoup quand même est ce
que vous sentez l'engouement kg et qui
monte dans cette ville de versailles
j'ai l'impression que tout le monde en
parle place du marché ça ça mobilise
finalement pour l'équipe qui est une
ville qui n'est pas forcément foot à la
base on a l'impression que de plus en
plus ça parle foot ça c'est bien c'est
bien c'est l'effet coupe de coupe de
france et on va pas se plaindre de ça on
est oui on est conscient que il ya
quelques mois il y avait plein de
versailles qui sait même pas qu'il ya
une équipe de foot dans la ville
aujourd'hui on sait qu'à le château et
l'équipe de foot parce qu'on parle
beaucoup de nous peut être un peu trop
d'ailleurs tous mes
ça ça doit être l'effet demi finale de
coupe de france on les accepte ça donne
un joli coup de projecteur à notre
projet et on espère surtout que ça va
pas s'arrêter là le projet il va pas
trop vite justement et que cette demi
finale de coupe de france ah bah non il
va pas trop vite mais il nous permet de
pas de parler plus facilement de tout ce
qu'on a envie d'entreprendre à moyen et
à long terme de discuter plus on va dire
de façon plus plus chaleureuses et plus
est plus sympa
cordiales avec la avec la ville et ça
facilite beaucoup de choses dans les
relations dans les dents dans l'est les
contacts qu'on peut avoir aussi avec des
partenaires qui vont venir nous
rejoindre prochainement enfin bon
évidemment que ça mobilise plus
facilement les gens autour du de nos
projets il ya eu énormément de monde
pour ce quart de finale contre bergerac
place du marché ils étaient plusieurs
milliers avec des fumigènes à chanter
tout ça est ce que ça a galvanisé les
joueurs d'avoir vu ces images a je pense
qu'ils ont été
extrêmement surpris et agréablement
surpris ça montre qu'il ya qu'ils
connaissent ce soutien même s'il était
un peu un peu un peu loin mais mais je
pense que c'est une force et des ondes
positives qui ont été envoyées aux
joueurs qu'ils n'imaginaient sans doute
pas qu'il doit y avoir un tel mouvement
en leur faveur
dans la ville donc c'est bien ça veut
dire qu'à versa il ya sûrement de la
place pour le football et nous en tous
les cas on va tout faire pour qu'il ya
de plus en plus de supporters dernière
question c'est ce jour notre petite
question habituelle à tous les deux
jean-luc arrive à un pronostic sur sur
cette rencontre va comme d'habitude on
va les écraser à 1 0 ou alors ou alors
on va se qualifier aux tirs au but merci
à vous
toute la ville et tout le club vibre
pour cette grande première historique
pour les ivy nous sommes allés à la
rencontre des jeunes du club ils
soutiennent évidemment leurs aînés des
images de patrick jacques de dixmude
un champ répété en boucle cette semaine
lors de ce stage de football à
versailles à quelques jours de la demi
finale historique face à nice les jeunes
du fc versailles 78 ne cesse de parler
des exploits de leurs aînés dans cette
coupe de france 2022 un parcours qu'ils
ont scruté avec attention scénique assez
pour un club de n2 c'est bien est ce
qu'ils ont fait c'est extraordinaire
surtout face à toulouse le but djoko est
aussi une vie de diarrassouba contre
bergerac et qui se font passer les
quarts de finale huitième de finale
histoire qui vont passer au concret
c'est qu'ils ont gagné longuet du coup
j'ai supporté et marseille pour qu'ils
puissent gagner je veux les encourager
sur le terrain les 74 jeunes présents
tentent d'imiter les gestes des
demi-finalistes de la coupe de france
des joueurs devenus en quelques semaines
leur idole pour moi c'est une star ne
sai surtout que je coure marque beaucoup
mais qui du beau
handball en tous les cas dans tous les
cas c'est mon préféré de tous vers sa g
que vu de près vieira est l'entraîneur
et alors bon je l'aurais fait un check
et voilà l'équipe première qu'il rêve de
rejoindre dans le futur en fait avec
tous les enfants les eaux d'un enfant ça
nous ça nous fait plaisir scène donne du
courage pour venir jusqu'à ces niveaux
l'un d'eux national de voir plus loin
encore tous nous rassurer le regarderont
le match même si la plupart seront sur
leur lieu de vacances un rendez vous qui
me le rateraient pour rien le mot
[Applaudissements]
pour permettre à ses jeunes supporters
de rêver encore plus grand et pourquoi
pas une première victoire en coupe de
france l'entraîneur dé versailles et
youssef chibi un plan pour contrer les
ambitions à désigner des niçois nous
l'avons rencontrée alors youssef chibi
comment ça se passe cette dernière ligne
droite avant cette demi finale de coupe
de france contre nice ça se passe bien
sereinement les garçons se prépare avec
calme puisque on a un certain temps
devant nous pour pouvoir préparer cette
échéance ô combien importante et c'est
appréciable parce que ça nous permet
d'ouvrir cette parenthèse enchantée et
de ne pas arriver trop vite et trop tôt
dans cette rencontre
tranquillement montée en en excitation à
la proche du match mais l'idée c'est de
pas jouer le match trop vite et trop tôt
à notre niveau
on doit vraiment préserver les
psychologie de chacun dans le sens où on
a une échéance tellement important
tellement unique dans laquelle un joueur
de ce niveau là qui va falloir monter
crescendo voilà en pression et
c'est ce qu'on fait pour l'instant de
tous les garçons sont plutôt mûr nature
réceptionne bien tous les messages mais
il faut pas aller trop vite il n'y a pas
trop de justement de messages de
personnes qui envoient des messages qui
les font sortir peut-être de leur bulle
l'engouement est présent aujourd'hui ils
ont intégré un engouement que ce soit
médiatique ou populaires à travers le
parcours j'ai des garçons qui sont
plutôt calmes dans leur esprit plutôt
solide et c'est vrai que ils sont dans
une dans une période de leur vie qui est
unique et singulière notamment pour un
joueur amateur et et pour l'instant il
gère très bien au niveau du staff on
s'appuie peut-être sur les légendes qui
ont plus d'expérience pour ce type de
rencontre
oui bien sûr chacun chacun apporte sa
pierre à l'édifice du calme et c'est
vrai que les relais de nos cadres qui
sont qui ont une histoire pour certains
avec la coupe de france notamment nous
permettent et permettent aux autres
d'appréhender des situations la
meilleure des manières jean luc a réparé
disais que vous avez environ 9% de
chances de vous qualifier face à
l'équipe de nice qui est troisième de
ligue 1 mais que vous allez jouer votre
chance à fond c'est bien ça le message
du staff également
après sur les pourcentages sacré jean
luc les identifier maintenant je sais
très bien que la tâche est immense dette
immense face à un adversaire
important aujourd'hui football français
qui va compter encore dans les années à
venir qui qui qui cherchent à se
qualifier pour la prochaine ligue des
champions donc nous on est que
quand nationale 2 voilà et on va se
déplacer
à l'alliance rivera c'est cet adversaire
qui fait de cette coupe de france une
priorité donc mais à côté de ça on va
préparer la rencontre comme quand on
prépare toutes les rencontres pour la
remporter en observant l'adversaire de
la meilleure des manières je me suis
aussi déplacé comme je lé fais sur tout
l'est sur tout l'est surtout les tours
jusqu'à présent pour aller les observer
on va essayer de préparer un plan qui
nous permettra de contrecarrer et j'irai
à l'adversaire ça va être défensif ce
match avant tout pour versailles
ça va être un match va falloir avoir les
nerfs solides psychologique pour nous
pour nice
parce que derrière les chiens le
derrière c'est une place au stade de
france donc ce n'est pas rien et même
pour l'adversaire il va falloir je pense
qu'ils puissent voilà rester serein mais
ils vont avoir le soutien populaire de
leur stade leurs habitudes donc ça sera
ça sera plus simple nous il va falloir
qu'on réussisse à appréhender tout
l'environnement qui sera complètement
inhabituelle puisque on aura un stade
quasi plein avec un adversaire et un
public qui sera contre nous
une équipe de ligue 1 un entraîneur
partie des meilleurs entraîneurs
français si c'est une meilleure
aujourd'hui donc il ya beaucoup
d'éléments un peu contre nommé mais on
est là on est à ce stade de la
compétition on va essayer de déjouer les
plans à notre manière et
j'espère déjà qu'on pourra réussir le
match qu'on veut réussir ensuite le
résultat il arrivera ou pas mais qu'on
puisse arriver est terminé cette
rencontre sans regret le fait que ça
soit lisse et forcément des avantages à
nice oui
c'est une déception départ parce qu'on
aurait vraiment voulu faire partager sa
tous les versailles et à tous les
franciliens qui nous soutiennent notre
région sur nos terres d'avoir ce soutien
populaire qui parfois nivelle les
valeurs avec les équipes
professionnelles mais la déception est
passée rapidement parce qu'on a on a ce
match à préparer
il faut qu'on se mettre dans les
conditions qui nous permet d'être d'être
performant et avoir cette expérience
unique et d'un stade de ligue 1 qui sera
quasi quasi plein c'est aussi un bon
moyen pour les joueurs de ses souvenirs
et de revenir en arrière quelques années
plus tard et de se dire on a fait un
match de ce niveau là dans ces
conditions ça va vous servir peut-être
pour la suite du championnat et peut
être les prochaines années on souhaite
en tout cas le club à grandir à travers
ce parcours à travers cette lumière mise
en avant parce que on a un projet qui
s'est mis en place récemment et toute
cette lumière nous apporte aussi un peu
de crédit peut rassurer de potentiels
sponsors à terme
rassuré aussi des futurs joueurs qu'on
voudra recruter un moment donné donc se
dire que versailles c'est un club qui
veut grandir à son rythme sans pour
autant aller trop vite non plus sans se
prendre pour d'autres mais mais voilà on
un club qui se veut ambitieux et qui se
donne les moyens qui travaille pour qui
travaille dur pour essayer d'avoir des
résultats on parle beaucoup de
versailles en ce moment peut-être
beaucoup trop ou pas est-ce que ça vous
dérange vous
moi je suis un homme de terrain donc que
les résultats puissent être mises en
avant à travers ce parcours de cours
bien sûr ça s'entend mais mais on est
plutôt discret en général à versailles
et c'est vrai que cette lumière cette
saison et est importante il faut
l'appréhender il faut rester et garder
les pieds sur terre
mais c'est vrai que la discrétion me
correspond et correspond plus à mes
joueurs donc c'est pour ça que il ya des
exercices notamment cet abattage
médiatique n'y a à ce stade de la
compétition et au parcours qui est
complètement entendable et c'est normal
mais on aime bien être entre nous voilà
on est discret versailles en général un
dernier mot peut-être eu un pronostic je
sais pas si vous avez savante être où
vous aimez pas trop vous vous livrez à
ce petit jeu pj rial vous parlez réagi
ou non moi je les pronostics et moi je
suis entraîneur donc je prépare les
rencontres pour les remporter pour se
qualifier et donc on va tout faire pour
même si on sait que ça va être difficile
une tâche
je dis qu'à quasi impossible il a quasi
donc il ya peut-être quelque chose à
faire mais en tout cas il va falloir
réunir beaucoup d'ingrédients pour
essayer de contrecarrer les plans niçois
merci ou sashimi
parmi les joueurs sur lesquels youssef
chebbi compte s'appuyer évidemment le
capitaine mail durant de jeu vigne et le
joueur a grandi au club il nous parle de
son parcours dans cette interview
express
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
suis arrivé après avoir joué ce rôle
dans le club de ma ville j'ai fait
quatre cinq années un peu d'écoles de
foot et jusqu'à u16 à peu près après je
suis parti dans d'autres clubs de la
région parisienne et voilà ça n'a pas
trop marché j'ai pas pu aller au niveau
que je souhaitais du coup je suis
revenue là en senior en nationale 3 et
là c'est ma quatrième année on a fait la
montée en national d ela on aspire à
aller le plus haut possible
[Musique]
ce sera un peu moins avancés mais je
sais que c'est toujours ça a toujours
été un club cas de bonnes
infrastructures pour les jeunes qui met
les moyens qui est très bien encadrés
par des bonnes personnes et là avec
l'arrivée des actionnaires qui nous
aident pour essayer de franchir un cap
c'est c'est quelque chose de bien pour
le club et ça me fait plaisir de voir un
club des yvelines qui arrive à ce niveau
là
honnêtement je reste concentré sur sur
sur ce que j'ai à faire sur le terrain
tout ce qui est média honnêtement c'est
un plaisir de voir que les gens parlent
de moi et reconnaisse le travail le
travail et moi après ça ça me touche ça
me fait plaisir mais je suis pas là à
m'enflammer ou quoi que ce soit je reste
focus sur le terrain je sais ce que j'ai
à faire j'ai des ambitions et je vais
tout faire pour les atteindre alors
quelles sont vos joueurs préférés
chouchou mike brant j'ai signé c'est un
petit peu rigoler chebah dans le
vestiaire sur cette vidéo
on l'avait regardé gestion juste avant
un match de championnat on était tous
ensemble et on a bien rigolé il sent
fort
si nous sinon on n'y croit pas acquis
qui va croire pour nous quand vous
regardez les pronostics ou ce que disent
les gens forcément on part perdant parce
qu'on est on joue là bas je vous fasse à
un très gros ligue 1 mais nous on est
convaincu que on a notre notre pièce à
jouer et qui est on à ton âme niveau
pour essayer de les embêter un peu et
d'aller accrocher quelque chose
on passe maintenant au reste de
l'actualité sportive yvelinoise
on passe au coup de projecteur sur les
autres sportifs du week-end dans les
yvelines mon acolyte c'est bixente mais
rien senti steban nous a rejoint sur ce
plateau bonsoir bixente sans michael
alors de quoi allez vous nous parler
aujourd'hui du football tout d'abord un
petit peu de football puisqu'il n'y a
pas trop parlé aujourd'hui mais il n'ya
pas que versailles dans le département
même si la plupart des clubs sont en
vacances actuellement pas de repos en
nationale 3 et même un gros derby entre
mantes et les mureaux résultat 0 0 qui
conforte le club des mureaux en milieu
de tableau tandis que man tu restes
toujours en course pour le maintien
alors en football ça ne jouait pas
beaucoup 1 ce week-end mais dans les
autres sports wii à bixente oui en rugby
notamment avec la 17e journée de
fédérale 2 plaisir l'a emporté sur la
pelouse de l'avant-dernier du classement
domont le score 27 à 29 pour les
plaisirs oies qui reprennent des points
à leur concurrent direct pour une
accession en phase finale en revanche il
y à des clubs chinois pour lequel pour
lesquelles la qualification en phase
finale est presque déjà assuré michael
alors en fédérale 3 verset maisons
laffitte et où il occupe trois des cinq
places qualificatives exactement le rc
versailles et premier a conforté sa
première place en s'imposant à dieppe 17
à 54 avec en prime le point de bonus
offensif son dauphin c'est le mlsgp qui
a résisté à evreux les troisièmes en
obtenant le point du les points du nul
ce qui est assez rare en rugby le score
20 partout enfin à huy a battu rouen 34
à 45 et conserve sa quatrième place à
neuf longueurs des cinquième camp alors
en parlant d'eux quand ils allaient
affronter trappe en nationale 3 de
basket ce week end oui les trappistes
ont su s'imposer assez facilement il
faut dire 91 à 73 face au caen nord
basket
la précision est importante quand hors
basket puisque trappe partagent la
deuxième place du classement avec
l'autre club de la ville l'as ptt caen
en basket féminin maintenant l'entente
le chesnay-versailles recevaient les
premiers de leur division 2 nationale 2
le csp nantes et le fcv s'est incliné 59
64 et cède ainsi la première place d'un
championnat très serré puisque le club
se retrouve désormais à la quatrième
position lors bixente vous nous apportez
aussi des bonnes nouvelles de montille
brunner vous êtes comme ça oui plutôt un
ouf de soulagement il faut dire vous
n'êtes pas sans savoir mickaël que les
féminines de montigny éprouve quelques
difficultés cette saison ce week-end
elles ont renoué avec la victoire hors
de leurs terres le score 25 23 face à
issy paris c'est la première victoire à
l'extérieur désigne monteyne depuis le
25 septembre dernier et c'était sur le
terrain de draveil et ça commence à
dater et pour terminer on prend des
nouvelle d'arthur rhino cnes oui arrive
bien après sa défaite lors du premier
tour du tournoi atp de dubaï face à
l'espanyol et 15e mondiale roberto
bautista à goutte le français est arrivé
à pau pour disputer la coupe davis avec
l'équipe de france face à l'équateur des
matches programmés le 4 mars le 4 mars
prochain au palais des sports de pau
merci bixente pour toutes ces précisions
vous retrouve la semaine prochaine et
avec une victoire de versailles on
l'espère alors on va maintenant à
prendre la direction des murs aux
pourparlers a break dance le pôle
espoirs de l'équipe de france est venue
dans la commune pour présenter cette
discipline qui sera présente pour la
première fois aux jeux olympiques de
paris en 2024 un reportage de céline
charme ils sont dans les 50 meilleurs de
france les jeunes du pôle espoirs de
l'équipe de france de break était en
stage aux mureaux pendant une semaine
au programme entraînement physique
intensif et démonstrations devant un
public novice mais visiblement conquis
je connaissais pas mon fils de 6 ans
qu'il en a fait j'ai suivi les cours et
franchement ça m'a plu c'est normal
maintenant je participe à à des shows
comme comme cela on n'avait pas ça avant
je parle de 2018 2019 le moment c'est
s'est concrétisée avec les jeux
olympiques c'est vachement cool tout ça
qu'on puisse avancer à disposition
vraiment cette équipe et c'est cool mais
passer ses capacités coupé à savoir
l'internaute soit espoirs dépassé
que physiquement on travaille sur les
mains on travaille sur la tête des
choses qui sont pas forcément faciles
l'occasion aussi d'attirer de nouveaux
adeptes lors d'une initiation
difficulté à y gagner ce qui m'a plu sic
et bat on s'entraîner tous et puis on
regarde et on pouvait refaire les mêmes
figures une discipline qui se
démocratise de plus en plus avec son
entrée aux jeux olympiques 2000 24 à
paris avec les jeux olympiques vraiment
ça donne une ampleur qu'on n'aurait
jamais pensé c'est pas du tout ça fins a
pas du tout été créé pour ça la bosse
donc vraiment c'est cool de voir une
évolution qui paissent de quelque chose
qui a été fait dans les rues et s'étend
sur des cartons à l'arrivée aux jeux
olympiques donc pouvoir être médaille
olympique diop agios le break est une
culture qui est quand même assez suivi
on le voit même dans des événements pas
forcément fédéraux que ça attire le
public parce que c'est
intergénérationnel les parents viennent
avec leurs enfants ils passent un bon
moment c'est un vrai enjeu pour notre
territoire nous représenter le break il
est référent des vies française pour
l'organisation et la mise en place
d'actions autour du braquet un événement
qui prouve la volonté de faire des
mureaux une terre de breakdance prochain
rendez vous le championnat
interrégionaux de breaking le 2 avril
prochain
et on termine par du cyclisme le
paris-nice s'élancera ce dimanche depuis
la commune de mantes la ville à partir
de 13 heures pour une boucle de 160
kilomètres à travers le département et
le val d'oise le peloton passera
notamment par houdon ou encore
magnanville le lendemain c'est la petite
commune d'auffargis qui va accueillir
les stars du cyclisme pour un départ aux
alentours de 12h15 le département
accueille le départ du paris nice depuis
treize années consécutives c'est la fin
de cette émission merci d'avoir suivi à
bientôt sur tv 78 et surtout aller
versailles
[Musique]